this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck this
podcast has bad words
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist and it's my freaking
birthday episode it is time to celebrate
heck yeah come on studio audience
we have a special guest my lovely wife
yes see jordan's not clapping because i
think he uh he just doesn't like mariah
is the problem neither deshawn this is
unbelievable i'm so sorry i'm right
usually we have a much warmer welcome
but i don't know what's going on with
[Laughter]
no um they're working whatever magic
they're working over there on the
cameras and audio even though sean isn't
even plugged in i'm not sure what he's
doing
now ryan you said you want you begged
can i please mariah please can i have a
threesome on my birthday
[Music]
is this what you imagined it's exactly
what i was talking about yeah a
threesome on my birthday
well happy birthday to you you're you're
turning 40 uh as we're recording this
three days ago from the day this comes
out so it's really your birthday week
and it's time to celebrate that's right
man birthday week i've never understood
that like it just seems like a um
i don't know an excuse yeah to celebrate
all week to celebrate your birthday oh
wait why don't we just have my birthday
here that's
well we do that with ella you know she's
she turned eight uh earlier this year
and and when i told her it was her
birthday month because she her
birthday's toward the end of the month
she was so excited oh it is
it's like it's not just one day it's my
whole birthday and we didn't do anything
different right yeah i don't do anything
different on her birthday versus like we
we just celebrate all the time but like
there was a significance in her mind i
want to talk to you about that today
because turning 40 for a lot of folks is
a milestone and i would love to get some
perspective from mariah here sure as
well yeah and so i know we've got some
audience questions before we dive into
that though on this minimal episode
we're going to talk about
the wisdom that is gained from
getting older what is the difference
between wisdom and knowledge i also want
to talk to you about maturity but on the
maximal episode this thursday over on
patreon we're going to disagree about
attachment
we're going to um we're going to get
some lessons that ryan has experienced
especially recently but what have you
learned over the last four decades what
have you learned over the last year so
we're going to talk about that over on
patreon plus
we're going to hear about mariah's
relationship yeah that's their couple
name by the way mariah or ryrie i kind
of like ryrie
i don't even know what that is ryrie oh
that's just your name twice no more
nicknames
ryan
ryrie
all right anyway we'll hear more about
their relationship this week on the
maxwell episode a little bit here on the
minimal as well i wanted to start by
talking about what is
maturity what is wisdom
because i think sometimes we confuse
maturity with age yeah i don't think
i've like figured out what maturity is
yet
i know wisdom is something you get right
after you needed it
i think that that's a dece a decent way
to look at it right you gain wisdom from
from experience right and so you don't
have it going into experiencing the
thing right i put together some of my
favorite quotes about wisdom but before
we get into that i'd like to talk about
maturity and i've really understood you
and i know some people who are really
young who are mature yeah right yeah but
we also know some old people who aren't
mature at all
and i think one of the the the key
indicators of maturity is one's
willingness to
stop the blame
now that starts with blaming others
but also
blaming our circumstances blaming
ourselves even
and we can take responsibility without
pointing the finger or even pointing the
finger back at myself
and i think the
the most mature people i know
are never trying to offload or abdicate
their
responsibility
onto other people
so you're positing that maturity is
taking full responsibility for yourself
your life your actions rather than
yeah rather than yeah because i always
like the maturity is like oh i'm not
gonna make that butt joke
you know like that's mature to not make
that that butt joke
um but i love me a good butt joke
yeah
what's fascinating about that is
the
the
the jokes the silliness the childlike
behavior there's so much wisdom
in children yeah and don't we use that
term pejoratively you're being so
childish
yeah but maybe that's a compliment right
so just say thank you if someone tells
you you're acting childish and children
when they're really young they're not
blaming anyone for anything now right as
soon as they start to get acculturated
start to get programmed and they don't
want to take responsibility they start
acting like children in that respect and
so maturity is basically
seeing the situation for what it is and
not blaming other people for my own
problems my own upset my own anger for
the things that arise in me
it's not their responsibility i think it
also has something something to do with
uh considering others
so taking people into consideration
because i think of like some immature
people i know
they're not thinking about how their
actions affect others yeah and i mean
we're not responsible for other people's
happiness or well-being
but we certainly have an influence over
how someone feels yes so yeah i think
there's an aspect of maturity there too
that you you start to think about how
are my actions going to influence others
it moves from a sort of me mindset to a
we mindset and eventually
the people who are most mature
they know what they do and how they do
it and how that will affect other people
and even if they know that hey i'm not
responsible for making you angry if i do
something
that i know is going to make you angry i
can avoid
the anger arising within you yeah and so
i think that's a true sign of maturity
mar let's talk about wisdom
because you have
you've been with ryan man how long has
it been now 2013
yeah so eight years
yeah eight years eight years yeah
and mar is uh
she's she ju she's getting ready to turn
27 for the eighth time
i told her that's how i would i keep her
on my life just don't ever get older
than 27. it's worked out really well for
you yeah right yeah yeah so that's funny
like doing the math on that 27th for the
eighth time took me a second to come up
with that well if it's eight years it
shouldn't have taken you that long
that's a good point it's a good point so
here's some quotes for you about wisdom
and i'd love to unpack them with you uh
three of my favorite thinkers anthony
demelo kapil gupta and jay krishnamurti
have have some quotes here here's what
anthony demelo says wisdom tends to grow
in proportion to one's awareness of
one's ignorance um
man i was
i was uh
so much smarter when i was 21
and so much less wise
because i think we sort of cling to our
rightness
and there's no wisdom in clinging
there's no wisdom in being right there's
no need wisdom in needing to be right
either
here's another quote from
gupta wisdom lies and investigating
one's foolishness
not correcting it
so
so
investigating our own because we're all
foolish to some extent now that could
mean just foolish because we've been
programmed with a misunderstanding of
the way that things are um or we're just
ignorant to what's going on now of
course what the society dude it tells us
to correct these things that's not what
wisdom is
wisdom is simply understanding that
foolishness and i think if you
understand it wholly in any particular
area it begins to sort of dissipate on
its own yeah you no longer need to be so
right all the time yeah it's interesting
like the older i get the more i realize
like i don't know
i mean i know some things
but
i i i don't know more than what i do
know well knowing and wisdom i think are
a little bit different too
not in a definitional sense but like
let's talk about what the the difference
but because i used to and i think we use
them interchangeably and that's fine if
we mean whatever we mean that's not a
big deal
but
knowledge is one thing so like i can
pick up an encyclopedia and read about a
boat
and never have been on a boat yeah and i
can learn about the sail and how the
boat is built and i can have a thorough
intellectual understanding of boats and
sailing
but
wisdom comes from that first time i get
sea sickness
yeah you can't get that from the
encyclopedia it's true and so there's
something there about
experience immersive experience that
brings us wisdom that's why i wanted to
talk to you about this today because you
have 40 years of experience
and and so there is the
you can have the understanding in fact
anthony demello has this great parable
about
if he walks into a room right now and
there was a pit vipers crawling on him
and he was like hey guys you know what i
read the encyclopedia britannica and it
told me this pit viper you know what
if it bit me right now i would die in 30
seconds
could you please give me uh some
instructions on how i might remove this
pit viper from my arm
that's knowledge i've read all about the
pit viper the color it gets up to six
feet in length and and i know have all
of this knowledge
but there's no wisdom in any of that
because wisdom would be okay i need to
remove this from me immediately
otherwise i'm in grave grave danger
and so i think there's something about
the experience there
that it that makes it different from the
knowledge itself i think it's one of the
reasons that just reading books on their
own can be so
um they can be fine
but
it may actually prevent us from getting
the wisdom that we get a whole bunch of
knowledge without actually gaining the
experience of wisdom here's one more
quote for you from j krishnamurti
there is freedom only in seeing the
truth of what is and wisdom is the
perception of that truth
so
not the way that i wish things would be
if only x y and z would happen then i'll
be happy if only these circumstances
would conform to my preferences
then
this will happen well that's not that's
not wisdom wisdom is seeing things for
how they are right now
and and the only way we get that is
through the experience
yeah so when turning 40 are you
celebrating what are y'all doing oh yeah
what are we doing honey i think we're
gonna go to the van gogh exhibit yeah
and then make ryan's favorite german
dinner that's right yeah she's a bunch
of bratwurst
she just boils up a pot of them and
pours them on my face
that's pretty much it hey i'm not gonna
kink shame you whatever you're into no
she she does such a good job uh
she recreates like what my oma uh has
done in the past and
she's been able to experience that meal
that my that my oma makes um but yeah
it's just like
it's potato dumplings
sauerkraut
german potato salad and uh some like
delicious pork
pork chops pork loin
yeah normally no it's not schnitzel
no schnitzel is like the cliche german
thing that
when we went to germany like
we went on we arrived in berlin we went
out of our way to go find some schnitzel
and we had it and it was great we're
like oh this is good and then we went to
um bavaria to like like munich where my
gran my oma my grandma's from and after
like the sixth schnitzel down there we
were like all right no more schnitzel
like you get sick of it pretty quickly
anyway well happy birthday to you we got
some questions here from our audience do
it caitlyn from facebook has a question
for us
how have your needs in a romantic
partnership change as you move towards
your 40s
mark how have your needs changed since
you've been with ryan do you feel like
your needs have changed at all okay
because i was gonna say i'm not anywhere
near 40.
my needs how have they changed i think
that my needs have changed just in
the way that i have um
matured if you will and knowing that
ryan just augments and make my life
better but he's not responsible for any
sort of
happiness or the way that i feel in
general
and so i'm responsible for that and then
um
yeah i would say that's the biggest
biggest change it sounds to me like
there's almost a decluttering of the
need i think one of the things that we
do when we're really young is we're very
needy
and in fact you know we're going to talk
about this a bit on the maximal episode
because attachment kids are naturally
attached to their parents but then there
is this period where we have this period
in our teens usually there's this period
of rebellion you went through it you
went through it i went through and it
varies by individuals some people go
really wild in their teenage years my
wife was certainly that way
now other people they just rebel
slightly you know it's like oh my dad
wanted me to be a philosopher but i
decided to be a psychologist yeah and
it's like that's how i rebelled right
yeah whatever it is there's a slight
rebellion so it's i'm going to be my own
person but then what do we do when we
become when we grow up we start getting
in these relationships with other people
oh i need you for my happiness
i need you for my contentment i need you
for pleasure i need you to complete me
and what's beautiful about what you just
said mar is like there isn't you're
already complete without ryan and and
the word you use i think was augment and
ryan augments your life in really
beautiful ways
he might drive you crazy sometimes too
no never
but but even if he drives you crazy or
if he drives me crazy that's that has
something to do with our expectations
and an expectation is a type of need
it's needing some sort of outcome in the
future and so i think in a way ryan by
by getting older one of the things we do
is
by getting more wise i should say
often correlates with getting older we
start to drop some of those superfluous
needs in our lives yeah yeah i'd agree
with that it's an interesting question
because i'm i'm trying to think like
the biggest just in general things that
have changed in uh the way i approach a
romantic relationship
over the last 40 years um
if anything it's all at all it has
nothing to do with my needs as much as
it has to do with
like who i am in the relationship and
how
i contribute and also like how i react
to certain situations i mean
uh i very much like
you know
my feelings would get hurt very easily
in different ways and when my you know
her people hurt back
um so i have had to like kind of
recognize that on myself and not hurt
back can you maybe talk a little bit
more about that because i think that's
that's really helpful for the audience
who's listening because what you're
saying is in previous relationships if
someone hurt you because you had a
particular need you would then lash out
at them in some way sure i mean whether
it's like uh you know it's yeah someone
you know
one of my partners would say something i
don't know man uh you know you don't do
x y or z and maybe it's true
and i can look at that and be like oh
wow they're right um now i'm hurt and
now i'm so hurt like i want them to feel
the same hurt that i'm feeling so then i
would go back and be like well you know
what you don't do a b or c yeah and then
it just you know that's that's
escalating the situation so maybe that's
another way of looking at it is i just
really have gone on my way to
de-escalate as much as possible in in
the relationship uh i don't need
to yeah to hurt
someone back when they hurt me
essentially yeah that sort of what about
ism
that's a never-ending cycle oh you
didn't do this well what about when you
didn't do or i didn't do this what about
when you didn't do this sure and then
and then we get really caught up in it
because that is the self-righteousness
right yeah um i need
and i think the problem is like
yes you may have said i didn't do x y
and z right i didn't do the dishes i
didn't clean up after myself uh i wasn't
considerate yes i forgot your birthday
oh but what about when you did
this
somehow that justifies my bad action
right yeah and also it presupposes those
are bad actions
maybe
it there's an expectation
um gap on both sides yes i didn't do
that that and that
are you saying that i'm supposed to do
these things or that was your
expectation yes i can be sorry that i
didn't meet your expectation but your
expectation has very little to do with
me it's an expectation of me yeah in a
way
yeah i feel like you all have i have let
go of many of those expectations i've
seen that between the two of you i think
so and i think one of the other biggest
changes is
um you said you react to a lot of things
and i know like most of my life i've
just been reacting to everything that
happens but i think one of the biggest
um growing moments is learning how to
respond as opposed to react and
to be able to take what you say instead
of just lashing out because i know i i
was a big hurting back type person for a
long time of
taking it internalizing it
thinking about it and responding as
opposed to just
lashing out yeah that's a good that's a
good yeah you said reacting versus
responding responding yeah well that's
good
yeah i g one of the ways that i can kind
of catch myself
in those moments
is
like i will try not to take offense like
when someone hurts my feelings the like
the question i have to ask myself
is like mariah says something it hurts
my feelings which i can't take the last
time she's done that but i gotta ask
myself like oh is she trying to hurt my
feelings or
am i just responding to this uh in a way
that she didn't intend you know the the
contact she didn't attend that context
so that will help me
to uh
to respond a little bit better than just
reacting off of that hurt i can kind of
catch myself and
and really dive into like what what are
they trying to mean you do this with me
all the time like i'll say something and
josh is like now i know you don't mean
to be a jerk
so i'm not taking it that way
but you know what you said what like i
always say not terrible yeah whenever
ryan compliments you on something hey
that shirt doesn't look terrible on you
and he means it is like that looks
awesome right but but the way that it
comes out i there's some programming
there right um and i know what you mean
by that and so i but
i the reason i i will bring that up
sometimes because when you say it to
other people i hear you say it to other
people i can see their faces sometimes
they're like
did he just say it was kind of
terrible oh yeah i see yeah yeah
yeah so anyway i mean you know
questioning uh or not questioning but
rather not questioning intent and just
taking something for what it is right
yeah helps me to respond a little bit
better that's actually one of the four
agreements not to take anything
personally yes i've found that
i take everything personally and it
causes me a lot of uh internal
uh
problems yeah a lot of worry you know
worrying is just praying for bad things
to happen in the future yeah you can
tweet that podcast john the four the
four agreements talk to us about is that
the is that the book that's the book the
four agreements okay and they actually
do make a lot of sense and like that one
specifically i think it's been super
helpful i actually just reread that book
um a couple weeks ago and i think that
was for me i was like oh
that is
that's huge don't think take things so
personally because you're right like you
don't know what everyone's intent is and
nine times out of ten they're probably
just focused on whatever is going on
with them and you're not really a factor
in 100
process well yeah it's like when someone
says something negative especially a
romantic partner like a
it's going to
it's going to feel worse than what it
actually is just because you know you
have such a close relationship
but you know
your partner if they're if they're
saying something that maybe sounds
negative like you're right like they're
projecting a feeling that they have
inside and it's really that negative
comment is really about them it's not
about you
yeah and even a negative comment is just
how one perceives it there's no such
thing as a negative comment sure that in
in the sense that like ryan your shirt
is large
like that's a fact right it's literally
a large
but but like someone could perceive that
three or four or 750 different ways yeah
yeah and and so what i'm saying to you
or when you say when mariah hurts my
feelings it's not possible for her to
hurt your feelings
it's possible for me to interpret it as
oh mariah just hurt my feelings but the
true sign of maturity as we talked about
the beginning episode is saying
what you just said like oh that wasn't
her intention to hurt my feelings but
even if it is her intention in fact
especially if it was mariah's intention
to hurt my feelings my feelings would
actually be less hurt because then i
just know like stay away from this
person who wants to hurt my feelings
right that's like yeah that's how i look
at uh
you know any which we don't i don't get
a ton of them but you know someone comes
at me on twitter or something i'm just
like oh like this person is intending to
make me feel bad which really just tells
me that they're the ones who are really
feeling bad and i kind of can approach
it from a more compassionate standpoint
than a defensive
standpoint that's really helpful we have
a question here from alexis in galveston
texas what advice would you give to
people who
live with other people and
they don't share the same views
about minimalism
alexis i'm going to rephrase your
question here
to apply to ryan and mariah and then i
think we can expand it out to the
the broader world in general so are ryan
and mariah always in agreement regarding
their minimalist practices and if not
how do they find compromise with one
another
so another way to ask that question is
do you always agree on everything
of course not yeah i wasn't saying no we
probably don't agree on everything but
we're pretty well
we compromise really well like i think
we respect each other enough to
um
take each other's preferences into
consideration
and
do our best to
respect those yeah well you know
mariah does so much for our relationship
that like
i go out of my way
to see where i can do something for her
so the easiest thing for me to do really
is to
honor her preferences i mean most of her
preferences are very reasonable so
anytime that i'm like well i prefer this
way mariah prefers it that way like i
can think to myself like
[ __ ] man she does so much for this
relationship like this is a pretty easy
compromise for me to for me to uh bend
with her preference
and she will do the same exact thing and
that's i mean i think that's
with any romantic relationship or
relationship in general man yes it's
like you have to go out of your way to
respect the other person's preferences
look for reasons to respect their
preferences um
because when the big stuff happens i
can't even think of something big that
we
haven't been able to compromise on but
there are big things right like yeah
like you know like we we gotta you know
that raw four not too long ago
and like that's the last thing i was
like oh i really want to get a tacoma
because i used to drive tacomas yes and
uh
you know mariah like shared her
preference of like oh i'd rather not i'd
rather do something a little bit more
you know fuel efficiency fuel efficient
wise
and uh yeah like it's a very easy thing
for me to be like okay
me
picking this battle to like fight for
tacoma is stupid like it would be so
dumb
but but i think what happens in
relationships
like if i was to really put you know put
my
plant my flag in that uh that hill and
i'm willing to die oh no i want it to
come when we're going to get a tacoma
there's so much more deeper there's so
much deeper issues going on than just
like yeah yeah i mean i think what
you're illuminating here is there's a
difference between compromising your
preferences and compromising your values
yeah for sure now for some reason you
really deeply valued owning a toyota
tacoma and you could articulate that to
moriah i don't think it would have been
a problem there either probably not but
you realize like oh this is just a
preference thing right and i'm willing
to give up on this because i'm not
really sacrificing a preference what is
your real preference to have a vehicle
to go where you need to go when you need
to go there yes and the emblem on it
doesn't really matter that much right
even the functionality doesn't really
matter to you that much now let's say
that you valued it because you need to
haul lumber every week well that's a
different thing right if it if it aids
one of your values you don't want to
compromise your values for the
relationship bex and i got into this
recently on her podcast how to love
because uh well i realized like oh there
are some things i've been compromising
my values on in our relationship and it
was making me miserable yeah in fact we
we we did this relation this episode
called the misery of dependence when we
become dependent on someone it can make
us miserable dependent for our happiness
dependent for income dependent on
if we need the other person
in any way that's a type of expectation
and those expectations often make us
miserable and so yes we're all going to
have different preferences and i think
we need to honor those preferences if we
don't honor them then we're not being
considerate
and that's a sign of immaturity like if
i'm not being considerate to mariah
then am i really being the best version
of myself but if i'm being too
considerate if i'm addicted to tobex for
example the the i'm addicted to making
her happy
then all of a sudden
i've i've started compromising my values
and the person i want to be
in order for an outcome for someone else
here's the irony of that i can't make
becks happy you can't make mariah happy
in the moment it can feel like that
but it's up to her to respond however
she wants to respond and you can support
her
but that doesn't mean you're going to
get the outcome that you want within her
necessarily yeah yeah it's interesting
it's uh yeah
every time we we uh
we talk about you know the absolutes of
you can't make someone happy or make
them unhappy and you know all these like
i i don't know why but my brain goes to
like these
these instances where it's like yeah of
course yeah you can't you don't have
you're not responsible for someone
else's happiness but you know if i
uh cheated on mariah
then like that's going to i know that
that's going to create unhappiness
within her okay um
so yeah i mean it's it's it's not about
making the other person happy but it's
about really getting clear on
yeah what
what are the
boundaries i was gonna say expectations
but boundaries is probably a better way
to look at it like what are the
boundaries of the relationship
um and just yeah getting getting clear
on that but i think the biggest lesson
from this really is like
that i've learned is the more that i
give to the relationship the more i get
from the relationship now if i was with
mariah and like i was
constantly bending on my preferences and
she wasn't bending on any of her
preferences and it was this you know
that us box just really had all my
actions in there
then yeah then
i would have to look at that or vice
versa yeah of course that's what
happened to me and colleen when i wrote
about it and everything that remains is
i realize i stopped contributing to the
us box in the middle of the relationship
but i was still taking from the us box
and now all of a sudden no one i'm i'm
being parasitic
if if i'm just taking not giving now
it's not about giving it's not quid pro
quo that's not what you're talking about
at all
i'm contributing 51 she's only
contributing 49. and therefore i'm one
percent discontented yeah it doesn't
work like that it's giving what you can
when you can give it and there are
different seasons in life when my health
problems were their worst back in 2019 i
was barely able to contribute at all to
the us box
in my marriage and so understanding that
you can give what you can when you start
compromising your values that's a
problem well why is it a problem quite
often it's a problem because we don't
know what our values are so alexis i'm
going to send you a copy of our book
it's called love people use things
because the opposite never works there's
a values worksheet in the book in fact
there's an entire chapter in there about
our relationship with our values ryan
and i have identified these four
different types of values you have these
foundational values you have structural
values surface values and the dangerous
ones the imaginary values
and that can be a toyota tacoma it could
be oh i really really value this i'm
willing to sacrifice everything all of
my my relationships and and the people i
care about just so i can get that pickup
truck that i really want that's a that's
a good observation because i i'm
imagining there are a lot of couples out
there
who are
having very tumultuous relationships
because they're
planting their flag in the imaginary
values hill yeah and not realizing again
if that's if someone's in that
relationship there's something so much
deeper going on than
a tacoma that's right yeah now tacoma
for you it could be it could be a
surface value sure where it's a
preference that's really how i look at
surface values and those things change
all the time that's the cool thing about
surface values it's like the surface of
your house you might paint a new coat on
the wall you could change the siding on
the house and all of a sudden it
completely changes and your preferences
are the same way your surface values
change as your interests change as you
mature and get wiser many of those
surface values will change as well and
many of them will start to become
imaginary values and if you see them for
what they are you'll be able to drop
them so alexis will send you the book
book version or the ebook version or the
audiobook version which ryan and i read
ourselves if anyone else would like to
check that out you can just go to uh
minimalists.com you can find all of our
books over there ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages text your questions and
comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now mar you know this during
the lightning round this is where we do
our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media
and now you can find all of our minimal
maximums in one place thanks to our good
friend jessica lynn williams
minimalmaxims.com
we
how do you find equilibrium in your
relationship when an individual is on
their minimalist journey but their
partner is not there's some interesting
words in this question so individual and
partner and and also a relationship
so in the true sense a relationship is
not a a
real thing it's a concept it's it's how
two people
get along or interact with each other
right so it's not the separate thing um
although we we can look at that
conceptually so here's my pithy answer i
want to talk about it so i just took an
old phrase and reworked it here's my
pithy answer it takes two to tangle
hey yo
i see what you did there so
if something is complex it just means
two or more things are interwoven
together uh and so that that's the latin
root of it to interweave is complex and
so
we quite often get really tangled up
with the person we love but what tangles
us
it's almost always our desire for
something to happen in the future we're
never tangled think about the most
precious times in your relationship
the times that were most joyous
most fun most loving
it wasn't about the future it was always
about what is going on right now that
that sunset you watch together on the
beach you know the hike in the hollywood
hills snowboarding in montana together
just sitting by the fireplace and
staring in each other's eyes
there is this moment where there isn't
something on the horizon for you it's
all unfolding in front of you
right now there's no tangling of the two
of you it's just the two of you you're
present you're there
and that's
that's love there's no expectation
and there's really no attachment either
attachment has to do with the future as
well and we pick up those attachments
all the time saying attachments are
wrong you shouldn't have attachments
we'll talk about that on the maximal
episode as well but the tangling what
happens when we get tangled
well we start to lose our individuality
right
and that's the thing i was talking to
bex about
when i started compromising my values
i became tangled with
it wasn't even her expectations it was
what i thought she wanted
and don't we do that sometimes like oh
he'll be happy she'll be happy they will
be happy if i just do these three things
of course that never works not long term
it extinguishes some sort of immediate
discontent but then
new expectations always arise from that
yeah
i think it's unfortunate that ari
there's something going on where you
know someone is saying
my minimalist journey can't be complete
unless my partner's minimalist journey
is also in the process of being
completed yeah and that is um
it's just unfortunate because
you know i don't have to have
uh
mariah does not have to have the same
preferences as me or the same lifestyle
i mean i love mariah for who she is she
loves me for who i am so never would i
be like oh i would be healthier if you x
yes i mean that's just kind of a that's
the blame yeah it's the blame and it's
not that it doesn't mean that ari's
wrong here or the feelings are wrong but
these feelings do arise the question is
is like how do we process these feelings
so my pithy answer is compliance is not
a prerequisite for love
so another way to say that is their
journey is not my journey
and that's where we get caught up a lot
um when i hear people tell like you know
when we were in denver
and that
poor guy his wife gets up to the
microphone and she starts like
basically ragging him for the garage how
can i get him to do this and how can i
help him understand how can i convince
him she said yeah how can i convince
them and it's like there's no convincing
like if you love your husband and they
did there was a lot of love in that
relationship i could see
it's like love is not convincing someone
love is accepting someone for who they
are
and it's about uh yeah it's about
finding
a common ground with each other so
you know like if mariah wanted to take a
room and just have it filled with
clutter
i mean it's not my preference
but like i'd be like all right fine i
mean
dude when we first met how many pairs of
shoes did you have when we first met
well i think it's really cute because
you used to always say i had 30 pairs of
shoes when we first met but it was like
130
i was trying to be nice oh she did too
but
the reason you were trying to be nice is
what you were saying is
in your mind oh 130 is bad there's
nothing wrong with having 130 pairs of
shoes like there's nothing morally wrong
about it right if that's your preference
it's your preference if you don't have a
mausoleum of shoes
that's fine
yeah i'm kidding about being nice really
what it was is my mind i could only
picture 30 pairs right not realizing
that's a really big number for him
repairs the shoes right for me yeah not
realizing it was 130 pair ryan has half
a pair of shoes right exactly
[Laughter]
if you call them shoes oh man
oh ryan let's let's just expand this a
little bit before we wrap this up here
so
the question here and i think you really
illuminated that
the the problem with the question is
there's a question beneath this question
how do i find equilibrium
in my relationship when i'm not on the
same journey as my partner
this question presupposes that i'm
supposed to be on the same exact journey
i'm supposed to be perfectly aligned
simpatico with the other person
all of the time
but that's not what makes a relationship
interesting or fun or loving
in fact when that lady the thing that i
talked to her about uh in in denver when
she came up to the mic and she was
trying to she said how do i convince him
to get rid of the clutter in his garage
and
what i wanted to explain to her in that
moment is to convince him is to unlove
him in fact i think that's what i said
to her yeah
and so anytime we try to convince
someone that we our viewpoint is
singularly right
we've put up a barrier to love we're now
missing out on the love
that is right there
in you
happening all the time
we put up these barriers because we
think you should behave this way you
should behave this way you you and you
should behave this way and that's how
you're going to get my like my love
my applause whatever it is
that's how you know that i care about
you if we're always on the same page
well you don't have to be on the same
page right
i think about like different journeys
you're on mariah with uh like your art
with uh even the environmental stuff
and you don't you don't like you don't
pressure me to
follow along with you in those journeys
so
i don't know do you have anything to add
to the how you can separate the
your journey from my journey because you
really like she's never like we should
do this we should do
that i try not to be too prescriptive
but i would say that even if you were to
be on the same minimalist journey
your perspective and experience would be
completely different than the other
person so even if you're trying to be on
the same journey you're never going to
be on the same journey so there's no
point in really trying to be on the same
journey i think it's about
being on your own journey and finding
the people around you who can support
you and love you through that journey
and maybe
ideally i think if you have a partner
that maybe you're on your own separate
journeys but maybe you're moving in the
same direction or
um playing on the same team in a while
yeah exactly so it's like
i'm on my own journey you're on your own
journey um
hopefully that
that that they converge
you know that they um
they complement compliment thank you
well i'm thinking you conjure up this
image in my head of like you're playing
like
doubles tennis
and you would never want the two people
to always make the same motion
throughout the tennis match right and it
looked really cool it looked like a
synchronized dance right but it would
not be very effective in accomplishing
what you want to accomplish together in
fact it would be
counter-intuitive it would it would be
counter to
the things that you want to do together
that's it's not complementing each other
if you're doing the same exact thing on
the same journey yeah throughout you
don't want the same exact behaviors all
the time yeah it made me think how
you could be on this even if you were on
the same journey you're on two different
roads you're in two different paths yeah
so um yeah even if like you even if the
aria could
convince their partner to be a
minimalist they're going to be in two
separate
yeah like you said two separate journeys
or two two separate roads uh another
thing made me think of was um
like support is more effective than
coercion for sure yeah and so i think i
think the equilibrium comes when you can
um recognize the path that your
partner's on and respect it and support
them
um and if it's a path that you are
really like
can't get behind then maybe that's not
the partnership for you um amen yeah man
we got so much more to talk about but
first emma the immigrant what do you
have for us here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
hello josh and ryan my name is mandy
bender i am calling from lincoln
nebraska i'm calling today because i
have a great solution for what to do
with an old wedding dress especially if
it's kind of outdated and not likely to
be worn again the hospitals in my area
have a wonderful program that volunteers
who take old wedding dresses and make
burial gowns for infants i think this is
a great way to honor these children and
i know it is something the families
mourning the loss of a child will find
value in
hi this is jesse hazelwood in austin
texas and i was listening to
the podcast and a woman commented about
what's next i've decluttered and now
what's next and i think that i've
experienced some of the
anxiety that i heard in her voice
about okay now
now what and i think that i personally
still feel the need to veg out and not
work
and
[Music]
but at the same time
i will go and check my email and now
that is a joy to me because i've cleaned
it out and the emails that i'm getting
are telling me that i've got a new
podcast or
it's my favorite um
shopping site i really like fashion and
research and fashion
and
um but i get to sit down and enjoy that
and not worry about oh this isn't clean
my house is cluttered and i need to get
up and do something and have that extra
layer of anxiety on top
and then also
playing my guitar when i'm playing it
i'm not worried about
all the things that i need to do i can
actually sit down and enjoy doing the
things that i want and and finding joy
in my life all right ryan i want to talk
to you about the hedonic treadmill in a
second but first we have to thank your
wife for joining us today yes big thanks
to mariah coombe schneeberger nicodemus
isn't she lovely no no we haven't gotten
to the added value segment yet ryan
we'll get there by the way last week we
had mel robbins on the podcast the high
five have it and i realize why i haven't
been excited to do it because i'm real
ocd and i have there's smudges all over
my mirror now that's like it's funny
because she brings that up in her book
where she's like i know you're worried
about smudges trust me it's worth the
smudges
well i just have an extra you know
window cleaner glass cleaner there in
the bathroom now and i'll high-five the
mirror immediately just clean it off
real quick
and so it's the best of both worlds nice
i can maintain my composure my sanity
and also love myself a little bit more
and you can clean as you go
anyway this week uh this thursday
mariah's gonna join us for a long form
conversation over on patreon that's the
minimalist private podcast patreon.com
the minimalist but first ryan i want to
talk to you about the hedonic treadmill
so you and i have been touring a lot
over the last 10 years yes 11 years so
this is our 10th tour we're actually
right in the middle of it right now
ten tours in 11 years it's the love
people use things tour we're doing 20
cities throughout the united states and
canada and we were talking while we're
on the road this last trip we were out
in uh where the heck were we orlando
yeah and we were in atlanta oh my gosh
atlanta was such an amazing tour stop
yeah it was great by the way all these
tour stops if you can't attend any of
them if you want to great but if you
can't they're all going to be available
on patreon as we release those in the
coming weeks and months
but
as we were touring ryan we we stayed in
st petersburg florida because we have a
coffee shop there yeah we show up at the
hotel and it's a really nice hotel it's
a true by hilton very nice brand new
yeah yeah and i'm like i just noticed
like the the first time i get it like oh
this room's kind of kind of small
and oh this isn't as good as the hilton
garden inn we stayed at three weeks ago
or whatever no man it's just it's never
enough i mean i have to remind myself
when i get in that state of how you at
one point you
colin
and me
had to share a king-sized bed there was
one
you're right there was one night we the
three of us shared a futon that's right
in austin yeah we were in austin texas
and and so but there were also nights
plenty of nights around where we slept
in your toyota corolla
and we would have begged to to be in a
room like that and so this is a
cautionary tale for everyone even the
minimalists are not
immune to the hedonic treadmills as soon
as you become accustomed to something
and become very comfortable with it then
as soon as you remove that thing from
your life
it's like oh wait a minute but this
isn't as good and this is when we talk
about comparison being the thief of our
joy yeah it's really the thief of our
contentment
because we start looking for these
little things that are wrong and i
guarantee you if you look for something
wrong
you're gonna find it yeah you know i
don't think anyone is immune to the
hedonic treadmill i mean maybe there's
like a mystic out there you know a
buddhist or someone but for all intents
and purposes hardly anyone is immune to
the hedonic treadmill yes it's really
about like how do you deal up with these
how do you deal when the with these
impulses when they come up in your life
right that's the power is being able to
confront them not to ignore them not to
push them away not to not to not have
these impulses but really how do you
deal with them when they come up because
they come up for most people and how and
if you see them for what they are oh
this is absurd
because how awesome how lucky am i to be
here right now
getting to do this
and it's a reframing but it's not a
disingenuous reframe and it's not like a
just grit your teeth and bear it no no
this is
one of the luckiest things we ever get
to do we get to go out on these tour
stops by the way i put a list together
here ryan we've had a bunch of surprise
guests now we haven't announced these
guests because they've truly been a
surprise and so i'm not going to talk
we've got half the torso coming up in
january and february but we had dr john
delony who joined us in houston we had
ian kron what a great stop in dallas i
can't wait till he comes back on the
show man yeah yeah we had vve in salt
lake city yeah they did both of our
soundtracks and they perform music we've
had some special musical guests amy
stroup joined us in nashville what a
dream come true man oh my gosh that's
awesome her voice is so lovely and her
album tunnel we got to talk about it on
stage after the fact but she's she's
amazing canyon city joined us the
bergamot joined us in several cities as
well joanne cacciatore dr joanne
cacciatore she wrote a book called
grieving is loving we talked about grief
and trauma and death as well and that
was a special event it really was and
then anthony o'neil was supposed to join
us
i can't believe you're calling him out
i have to i love anthony o'neil and so
we're in orlando getting ready to go on
stage it's eight minutes before before
we go on stage right and so by the way
this is our right here right now segment
i really want to bring this back into
doing more of these where it really is
like what's going on in the life of the
minimalist we're eight minutes we're
going on stage i text anthony hey man
you almost here
and he calls me immediately he goes
don't tell me i'm supposed to be in
orlando right now
i'm like anthony funny joke ha ha
now's not the time for it yeah there's a
third chair on stage for a reason he's
like oh i didn't real and you know look
i know his honest mistake on his part
and
and whatever we'll we'll have him back
on the podcast at some point we
absolutely love anthony o'neil but um
yeah i think ultimately we just got to
blame ourselves man i mean well or or we
can ask people to tweet at him oh yes
and just give him a kind hard time yes
anthony o'neil he's one of our favorites
and of course tk coleman joined us for
two tour stops atlanta and nashville
yeah atlanta was one of my favorite tour
stops we've ever done period wow
unbelievable you'll be able to listen to
that really soon and by the way who
knows tk might join us for three or four
more other tour stops who knows wink
wink he could even be there with seth
godin at one of our tour stops in the
near future at an event that is about to
sell out so
by the way we've got a bunch of other
people i'm not going to ruin the
surprises for you but uh let's just say
maybe danae barahona will join us she is
awesome so she might join us maybe emily
oster is going to join us in an event
maybe lisa lampanelli will be at one of
the events
maybe a bunch of surprise musical guests
at these events maybe surprises in every
single city we've got 11 more cities to
go we'll be in new york and boston and
dc and chicago and toronto and
minneapolis and columbus and l.a and san
francisco
and seattle ooh and vancouver
and probably somewhere else that i
missed as well yeah but are we going to
toronto did you say toronto i did say
toronto okay and the musical guest there
oh
oh i can't wait i can't tell you
but it's going to be a beautiful
beautiful surprise love people use
things as the name of the tour the
minimalists.com
tour to find your closest city now ryan
since we've got out of the the hedonic
treadmill we've recognized oh wow what a
what a beautiful thing this is here's
another beautiful thing for you our
added value segment this week we're
going to change this up a little bit
this is the last time you're going to
hear a song on the public version of our
podcast there's certain copyright
restrictions so we'll still do added
value segments we'll still recommend
music or not even recommend but share
what's adding value to our lives uh next
week we're going to recommend some
products that add value to our lives as
well you're actually standing on one
right now
oh i thought it was going to be hair
products yeah he's standing on some hair
products
it makes him look taller yes
um anyway uh so we are gonna play a song
out but this is gonna be the last time
you hear a song on the public podcast
now on the private podcast what we'll do
is we'll just play you out every episode
because we can do whatever we want on
the private podcast no one's watching
that's right take that fcc yeah take
that government
i think it's more just youtube being
yeah frustrating anyway uh so this week
i know you and mariah really enjoy lee
dwise's music and by the way he might be
a special guest in some of the upcoming
cities maybe yeah you'll have to see he
just came out with a new album lead to
wise the album is called ghost stories
nominal album yes it's truly wonderful i
was driving with uh becks recently and
this album came on and then this song
came on and she just looked over at me
and she goes yeah
this is the one
so enjoy this song it's called quicksand
by letawise by the way we have a a bunch
more surprise questions this week ryan
like why do some people cling to toxic
jobs or work environments how did ryan
and mariah navigate moving in together
when it came to both of their material
possessions and what has been ryan's
greatest takeaway from the past 10 years
now that he is turning 40. let's look
back at his 30s and find the biggest
takeaway plus a million other questions
for mariahn
and the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app it's a completely separate podcast
every single thursday by the way you'll
also gain immediate access to hundreds
of hours of private archives recordings
of our live events monthly ask the
minimalist anything sessions and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers just like you
subscribe today patreon.com
the minimalists you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast just
email us a voice memo podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode over at youtube.com slash
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at
theminimalists.com we'll never send you
spam we'll never send you junk we'll
never send you advertisements but you
will receive our simple sunday email
newsletter for free
and if you leave here today with just
one message
let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it